اهلا بكم قبل عام قالت واشنطن وكذلك
الاتحاد الاوروبي انها مساله شهور وستنهار
روسيا لكن الاقتصاد الروسي ونسيجها
الاجتماعي وعلى عكس كل التوقعات امتصاص
صدمه الاولى
وتجنبها الانهيار لمحاوله فهم ذلك اتحدث
اليوم الى كريس ويفر رئيس منظمات مكروه
للدراسات والاستشارات الاستراتيجيه والذي
عمل لاكثر من 25 عاما مستشارا استثماريا
واستراتيجيا في روسيا انا مجرمه احييكم
اينما كنتم من العربيه وهذا البعد الاخر
[موسيقى]
من جديد احييكم في الايام التي تلت بدء
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا قبل
عام تعرض لاقتصاد الروسي لهزه خطيره مع
فرض دول غربيه عقوبات شديده على موسكو
فانخفضت قيمه الروبل الروسيه وضعف البنك
المركزي الروسي واسعار الفائده واغلقت
الحكومه بورصه موسكو
اكد البيت الابيض ان الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي لروسيا سينكمش بنسبه 15% ما
سيقضي على مكاسب روسيا في السنوات الخمسه
عشره الماضيه كما توقع الكثيرون ان يعود
اسلوب الحياه في روسيا الى ما قبل عصر
الهواتف المتحركه والانترنت بين ان هذه
التوقعات لم تحدث بل ان الاقتصاد او اداء
الاقتصاد الروسي كان افضل بكثير من
السنوات السابقه استمرت عائدات النفط
والغاز خاصه من بلدان التكتل الاوروبي
خلال العام الماضي في تعزيز ودعم الموارد
الماليه الروسيه كما ان المذهل ان
المبادلات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي ازدادت
بسبب تزايد تخزين الطاقه ما قوض اي تاثير
للعقوبات
كما وجدت موسكو ايضا مشترين جدد مثل الصين
والهند ودول اخرى طبعا واستمرت غالبيه
الشركات الغربيه في نشاطها داخل روسيا وقد
ادى ذلك الى تغييرات في المشهد
الجيوستراكي الدولي بظهور تكتلات جديده
وتنام الشعور القومي داخل الدول بل واعاده
طرح المثل الغربيه الامريكيه على طاوله
النقاش في الاعلام الدولي اسمحوا لي ان
ارحب في حلقه هذا الاسبوع من البعد الاخر
بضيفي كريس ويفر رئيس منظمه ماكرون
الدراسات والاستشارات اهلا بك معنا سيد
كريس اسمح لي ان ابدا معك بالسؤال عن
تجربتك عملت لاكثر من ربع قرن مستشار
استثماراتي واستراتيجي في روسيا ما الذي
توقعته انت لروسيا قبل عام عندما بدات
الحرب
الى شركه توقعنا بانه ستكون هنالك
تردي في الاوضاع الاقتصاديه ولكن الاطاله
ما توقعت بان
توقعاتنا انخفاض الحاده كان مبالغ فيها
اولا لان روسيا
اعتادت على التعامل مع العقوبات منذ عام
2014 منذ حادثه القرن فحصل التعديلات
كثيره في الاقتصاد الروسي عبر 8 سنوات
الماضيه وكانوا يستعدون للمزيد من
الاكتفاء الذاتي
والتنويع الاقتصاد
ونشاط الاقتصاديه وخاصه في المسارات
التجاريه على سبيل المثال في عام 2013
قبل بدا العقوبات
روسيا لم تقم ببيع اي نفط او غاز مباشره
الى الصين اما في العام الماضي او قبل عام
من الان الصين كانت اكبر مشتري للغاز او
الروسي خاصه عبر انابيب الغاز الرئيسيه
وكذلك مشترك كبير للغاز
والفحم والمواد الاخرى
فمساله التنويع حصلت اصلا
فكنا اتوقع انخفاض في الاقتصاد وقد
تفاجاتم
الى اي مدى تحسنت الاداء واعتقدوا ان هذا
ناجم عن حقيقه ان
روسيا كسبت اموال اكثر بكثير من التصيد
النفط والغاز والفحم والمواد الاخرى
لان اوروبا بكل بساطه ما عدا بس تحمل
تكلفه فرضي العقوبات على هذه المواد بسرعه
كبيره لانهم كانوا يعتمدون على روسيا بشكل
كبير جدا وبالتالي سمع حولي الروس لكسب
اموال اكثر ولفترات اطول والحكومه استخدمت
هذه الاموال لدعم الاقتصاد استدامه النمو
الوظائف وبالتالي
كانت نسبه الانخفاض اقل بكثير ما توقعه
الكثيرون لكنك تقول بانه اقتصاديا على
المستوى الاقتصادي روسيا لم تتاثر اطلاقا
بالعقبات والحرب بالعكس تحسن وضعها
لا لا استطيع ان اقول ذلك
لانها ليست الصوره واحده موحده الاقتصاد
الروسي باكمله اولا نتذكر بان هيكليه
الاقتصاد الروسي
لا تختلف كثيرا عن ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابقه مع اقصدهم بان قطاعات الدوله او
الدوله بنفسها تهيمن على الاقتصاد اكثر من
ثلاثيا الناتج المحلي الاجمالي تحت سيطره
الدوله بشكل او باخر وهكذا فان الدوله
تمكنت من المحافظه على النمو العام من
خلال دخل الاموال الى قطاعات الدوله ولكن
اذا نظرنا خارج هذه الصوره مثلا صنعت
السيارات وقطاع الاستهلاكي او التكنولوجيا
او القطاعات الجديده
فمساله الضعف كانت شديده مثلا
صنع سيارات تنخفضت بنسبه 40% في العام
الماضي وحتى
مبيعات الاستهلاكيه والمفرق انخفضت بعشره
بالمئه فهي ليست صوره موحده للاقتصاد
باكمله بل ان هيكليه الاقتصاد الروسي
[موسيقى]
خلال الازمات تتمكن فيها الحكومه بكل
سهوله من تحقيق الاستقرار على ارقام
رئيسيه ولكن هنالك يتنوعات كثيره غير ذلك
عبر القطاعات المختلفه كما ذكرنا من
الاقتصاد وهذا مشاهدناه في العام الماضي
وكذلك كما شاهدناه قبل عامين خلال جائحه
كوفيد 19 بعض القطاعات كان دعوها بكثير
ولكن الارقام العامه كانت افضل بكثير بسبب
دعم الحكومه لكن كما تعرف الكرملين توقف
اصلا عن نشر البيانات الاقتصاديه بعد وقت
قصير من بادئ التوغل العسكري في اوكرانيا
على ماذا بنيت هذه الخلاصات
نعم توقفوا عن اصدار البيانات او فيما يخص
المعلومات الحساسه فمثلا لاحصل على الكثير
المعلومات فيما خصم باقات الموازنات او
الحوالات الماليه واين الاموال مثلا لانهم
لا يريدون لهذه المسائل انها تكون معرضه
لعقوبه جديده قضينا وقتا طويلا لمراجعه كل
المعلومات التي يمكننا مراجعتها فمثلا من
جهه بيانات التجاره ليس من السيء مراجعه
هذه البيانات لان البيانات التجاره نحصل
عليها من الدول العميله مثلا الهند والصين
والامارات العربيه المتحده وتركيا وغيرها
فيكون لدينا اطباء جيد عن الارقام الروسيه
انها صحيحه او لا وبالفعل كانت صحيحه لان
استطيع ان نراجع حساباته والارقام من دول
اخرى
وانا في موسكو
واسافر
عبر المنطقه وحتى في منطقه مختلفه من
روسيا فنستطيع ان
نرى لو كان هنالك اثر على الاقتصاد فبلاكس
نلاحظ مثلا بعض محاله تسوق الكبيره او
المحلات الغربيه اغلقت والتي اغلقت لفتره
والبعض عده افتتاحها باسماء مختلفه ولكن
لا يوجد اي احساس بالانخفاض او الانحدار
الاقتصادي لا احد يتحدث عن خساره الوظائف
او انخفاض في الدخل في الحقيقه لمن يعيش
في موسكو الان
ولم يقرا الاخبار العالميه فما كان ليعرف
ان هنالك نزاع اصلا فلم يتغير الكثير
للحياه اليوميه للشعب الروسي
فيما يخص الظروف المعيشيه حصولهم على
الدعم الاجتماعي والوظائف وغيرها لم يتغير
الكثير على الارض
خلال العام الماضي
ولكن بلا شك نحن ندخل مرحله تحوليا حيث
العقوبات باتت اشد الان وبالتالي فان
الموقف في عام 23 بلا شك سيكون
او لا يصب كثيرا في مصلحه روسيا او اصعب
على اقتصاد الروسي ما كان عليه في عام
2022 لذلك اعتقد بان هذا العام اثر
العقوبات بلا شك سيكون اكثر وضوحا طيب
حضرتك بدات تتحدث عن الحياه في روسيا الى
اي مدى غيرت الحرب الحياه
بعد ان قيل في بدايه الحرب انه سيتم عزل
روسيا رقميا على الاقل بتعرف نظام سويفت
لا يتم التعامل فيه به في روسيا الم يعقد
هذا حياه المواطنين الروس
الى حد كبير لم يؤثر مثلا فيما يخص السفر
باتمان الصعب الان على اي شخص
ان يسافر من الغرب اوروبا والولايات
المتحده للدخول الى روسيا فعليه ان
يسافر الى دوله اخرى مثلا دبي واسطنبول
ومن هناك الدخول الى روسيا وهذا يعني بان
الرؤوس الذين اعتادوا على قضاء العطلات
مثلا في الدول المتوسط باتت خياراتهم الان
بين تركيا ودول الخليج العربي او ربما
الان بعض الدول اسيا فهنالك بعض القيود في
هذا الخصوص ولكن علينا ان نتذكر
ان الشعب روسيا وغالبيه الشعب الروسي
يعتمدون بشكل اكبر على الخدمات المحليه
والبضائع والمنتجات المحليه روسيا لديها
اكتفاء ذاتي مثلا في المنتجات الغذائيه
نتحدث عن ذلك على انه احدى فوائد العقوبات
على سبيل المثال خلال العوامل الثمانيه
الماضيه في عام 2013 كانت تسرد ثلثية
الغذائي الاستهلاكيه وبسبب العقوبات
للعوام الثمانيه الماضيه لم يعد لديها فقط
اكتفاء ذاتي بل باتت من الدول المصدره
للمواد الغذائيه ولذلك فان الشعب تاثر
بشكل اقل بكثير في حياتهم اليوميه وحتى
الانترنت
رقميا فهنالك بعض القيود ولكن في الحقيقه
مع استخدامي حتى خدمات الفي بي ان
الاساسيه في امكانهم متابعه القنوات
المحظوره
او التي حضرت على روسيا فمن الصعب القول
انه هنالك عرقله كبيره ولكن بالتاكيد مع
كل عمليات الحشد والشباب الذين
الاكثر سيطلب منهم الخدمه العسكريه وحتى
جيش الاحتياطي فهذا سبب عرقله كبيره عرقله
اجتماعيه
خاصه الشباب في هذه الفئه العمريه اصبحوا
هنالك خروج كبير جدا
خلال سته اشهر ما الذين غادروا روسيا
لتجنب الاستدعاء الى الخدمه العسكريه
حوالي نصف مليون شخص سافروا الى الدول في
وسط اسيا وانما نظرنا في مدننا مثل
اسطنبول ودبي
فنرى بكل وضوح وجود عدد كبير جدا من روسيا
هذه المدن
حيث يتجنبون
احتماليه نداءهم واستدعاهم للخدمه
العسكريه
فالى الان
الاثار كانت محدوده حتى على الصعيد
الشخصيه عده مرات خلال عام الماضي بعض
المنتجات ربما التي يستخدمها منتجات
استهلاكيه اختفت لفتره ربما لبضعه اشهر
لان الشركات اغلق المكاتبه ولكنها عادت
الظهور
تحت مخطط يسمى بالاستيراد المتوازي
الشركات الغربيه
السوق الروسي في زمن الحروب انه هناك
قطاعات تتاثر اكثر من قطاعات اخرى وقد
يكون قطاع السياحه مثلا في روسيا من اكثر
المتاثرين في ذلك بالذات من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي ارجوك ان تبقى معنا سيد كريستا
ويفر سنذهب لفاصل قصير نعود بعده للمتابعه
توقعات كريس ويفر عن مستقبل الحرب ابقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم معنا من جديد واتابع هذا الحوار
مع سيد كريس ويفر للحديث عن روسيا في
العام القادم بعد مرور عام كامل على الحرب
ودعني اسالك كنا قبل الفاصل نناقش
القطاعات التي تاثرت وكيف استطاع المواطن
الروسي ان يعيد صياغه التعامل مع الاسواق
المحليه لكن دعني اسالك عن الاموال التي
استثمرت في الاتجاهات من الاتحاد الاوروبي
تدفقت من الاتحاد الاوروبي برغم العقوبات
في اي اتجاهات وفي اي قطاعات صرفت في
روسيا
الكبير جدا خارج القطاع النفط والغاز
وخاصه في مجال التكنولوجيا لان العقوبات
اكثرها اثر انها كانت على القطاع المالي
وحيث وقطعتها حوالي كل بنوك الروسيه من
نظام سويفت والحاولات الدوليه وكذلك الحظر
على التكنولوجيا ايضا انتشر بشكل كبير
واضر بشكل كبير
بروسيا سيكون اكثر اضرارا خاصه عقوبات
القديمه لان روسيا تجد من الصعوبه
سراج اي شيء قد يعتبر من الاستخدامات
الثنائيه لاستخدامات المدنيه وهذا اثر على
قطاع السيارات ومجالات كثيره
مجالات كثيره من الاقتصاد بالتالي باتت
اساسيه اما
الاشخاص او الشركات غير القادرين على
الوصول الى احدث التكنولوجيا او المنتجات
التكنولوجيه والمنتجات الاستهلاكيه
وكان هذا ربما هو اكبر انحدار او اثر فيما
يخص التجاره مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي اوروبا الحكومه تستمر
بالحديث عن
بتوطين الانتاج هنالك خطوه ناجحه للتخلصي
من استيراد المواد الغذائيه واصبح لديهم
اكتفاء ذاتي ونفس الشيء يمكنني ان يتم
التكنولوجيا ولكن هذا امرنا شك فيه لان
التكنولوجيا
ولم يتمكن من الوصول الى احدث التكنولوجيا
من اسيا واوروبا واولايات المتحده
بلا شك
سيكون من صعبه جدا استنساخها فهذا احد
المجالات ربما التي ستعاني فيها روسيا
بشكل كبير
بسبب هذا الحظر على التكنولوجيا
بما يعني انه في اموال استمرت في التدفق
من الاتحاد الاوروبي على روسيا رغم
العقوبات هذه الاموال كيف تم انفاقها في
اي قطاعات وهل نتوقع استمرار هذا التدفق
الامر من جانبين اولا ان الاموال التي
كسبت ها روسيا من تصدير السلع الى اوروبا
خاصه النفط والغاز والفحم وماده اخرى
كلها فرضت عليه جدا لانه ربك كان عليها
تتكيف فيما يخص ايجاد المصادر فمثلا في
المعاضي روسيا كسبت حوالي
280 مليار دولار
مقارنه ب 190 في العام الذي قبله والكثير
من ذلك من اوروبا وكذا عبر
هي ليست من الاوروبينا والغربيين الذين
يستثمرون بروسيا بل الاموال تملكها
الروسيه اوغاركيه
في روسيا الذين كسبوا اموالا طائله خلال
23 عاما الماضيه
والذين استثمروا
اموالا طائله خارجه اوروبا في اوروبا وفي
الولايات المتحده وقد اعادوا هذه الامال
بسبب العقوبات ولانهم غير قادرين على
استثماره في اوروبا او دول اخرى فالكثير
من الاموال التي عادت الى روسيا في العام
الماضي كانت اموال روسيه عادت الى الوطن
وهذا الشيء بالتاكيد يناسب الرئيس بوتا
لانه تحدثا عن هذا الامر منذ عقدين
وقال هي عاده الاموال من الخارج وحاول حتى
هؤلاء الاشخاص الاستثماري
بالاموال الروسيه داخل روسيا بدلا من
الدول الاخرى ولكنه لم يحقق نجاح في تلك
العوام لغايه فبراير من العمل الماضي ومع
بدء العقوبات والان لاحظنا انحاء الاشخاص
ارغموا على اعاده اموالهم الى روسيا والان
يسعون لاستثمارها في روسيا فهي
الديناميكيه مثيره وسنرى كيف يتحقق
التوازن في كل ذلك فمن جهه هنالك انخفاض
كبير في الاستثمارات الاجنبيه والغربيه في
روسيا وسيستمر ذلك ومن جهه اخرى هنالك
اموال روسيه طائله عادت الى روسيا وسيسعون
لاستثمارها في روسيا دعم الاقتصاد
فديناميكيه مثيرا والى الان لا نعرف نتائج
كل ما ذكرته هل يمكن القول بشكل قاطع ان
العقوبات على روسيا فشلت
لا لا نستطيع ان نقول ذلك العقوبات
فشلت
[موسيقى]
في ايصال النتائج التي تحدث عنها الكثير
من السياسيين او التي يرغبون فيها اذا ما
سمعنا الى خطابهم قبل عام كان كحديث كثير
عن العقوبات والتي ستنجم عن ازمات مباشره
وفوريه داخل روسيا وانهيار الاقتصادي
ولمعايير المعيشه وبالتالي ستقود الى
انتفاضه شعبيه وتغيير في القياده وارقام
روسيا الخروج من اوكرانيا في ذلك
فشلت العقوبات تماما وتجد اي ادله على
حصول اي من ذلك الى الان ولا يوجد حتى
مخاطر من حصول ذلك ولكن من الجانب الاخر
اصبح لديها اثر بطيء فلم تكن او تحصل
هنالك ازمه حقيقيه ولا حتى احتمال وجود
ازمه عميقه في روسيا ولكن روسيا الان
تواجه
انحدارا بطيئا بسبب تراكم العقوبات
ولانها لا تستطيع ان تجلب الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه لانها لا تستطيع الوصول الى
التكنولوجيا الغربيه وبالتالي فسيكون
هنالك انحدار بطيء في الاقتصاد الروسي
وبالتالي سيؤثر على اسلوب معيشه الاشخاص
وجوده الحياه وانواع الخدمات المتاحه
للصناعه الروسيه والشعب الروسي كل هذه سوف
تزداد سوء من خلال سنوات المقبله فاذا
كفه واحده او في جانب واحد ونتساءل عن
تاثير هذه العقوبات على مستقبل الحرب
[موسيقى]
نعم ولكن مره اخرى من ملاحظاتي الشخصيه
هنا في موسكو والتحدث مع الاشخاص
اليهم اقول بان المزاج في روسيا ايضا الان
مختلف عن ما كان عليه في العمل الماضي في
العام الماضي كانوا اكثر خوفا وتشككا وحتى
غاضبين احيانا ما حصل
ومتخوفين ما سيحصل اما الان فاستطيع ان
اقول بين المزاج اصبح فيه تحدي اكبر
القومي ويرون بلا شك ان هذا النزاع الان
على انه حرب بين روسيا وبين الناتو وبين
روسيا والغرب
فقد انتقل بعيدا عن مجرد حربه اوكرانيا
فبات الشعب يرى ان اوكرانيا تحارب من اجل
بقائها وهكذا تغير المزاج والان هم
مستعدون لتحمل المزيد من الصعوبات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وبصراحه الى الان
لم يواجه الكثير منها ولكن ان حصلت فسوف
يتحملونها لانهم يشعرون بان بلادهم مهدده
وبالتالي فهذا شيء عليهم ان يتحملهم من
اجل بقاء بلادهم فالمزاج الان مختلف تماما
كثيرا من العزيمه والاصرار والعناد
والكثير من القوميه فاخشى ان لم يكن هنالك
اي انجاز سياسي فلا ارى ان الحكومه
الروسيه سترغم لا اقتصاديا او بسبب
العقوبات او حتى بسبب العام المحلي لا ارى
انها سترغم على عكس قرارها والخروج من
اوكرانيا تحت اي ظروف المعقوله لفتره
طويله جدا واذا ما انتهت الحرب
باتفاق سياسي مع الغرب ولن يكون بسبب
العقوبات الاقتصاديه او الضغوط المحليه في
روسيا او الهزيمه العسكريه في نهايه الامر
شكرا جزيلا لك سيده كريستا وفار رئيس
منظمه ماكرون للدراسات والاستشارات على
المشاركه في البعد الاخر لهذا الاسبوع الف
شكر والى هنا مشاهدينا الكرام انتهت حلقه
اليوم من البعد الاخر يمكنكم دائما
متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
يمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقتنا على العربيه
بودكاست ولا تنسوا منصه شاهد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]